hi my name is shin Messing I'm going to
present the perspective engine project
based on the research of Dan Goldstein
and Jake Hoffman from the New York City
rap this project started with basic
research on improving comprehension of
numbers in the news the idea is to
provide analogies to improve compression
of large and hard to grasp numbers this
has been in production in Bing for quite
some time
for example if you were doing a Bing
search like how big is France you not
only get the answer 248 thousand square
miles but also added context that that
it is about equal to the size of Texas
which is helpful to someone in the u.s.
let's take a look at another example how
many calories in a soda which is about
156 calories and perspective here is
about 12 minutes of running which is a
lot more familiar to people than 156
calories and this year a tech fest we
have seen an option from PowerPoint
designer team to do show perspectives in
the associations let's take a look at an
example now
let's say I was making a slide that
looked like this and it has a large
number in it like 120 million square
acres of land and the designer comes
back with suggestions that that is about
the area of California apart from the
cessations they also get nice image
background and beautiful looking slide
that is much more engaging to the
audience let's try another example at
this now
a slice of pizza has 400 calories and
that is about 32 minutes of running and
along with the perspective you also have
a background image with a pin sign in it
to find out more about this project go
to our website thanks for watching